the navy is charging a sailor with
starting a fire last year that destroyed
a warship docked off san diego
the amphibious assault ship the uss
bonhomme richard
burned for more than four days it was
the navy's worst u.s
warship fire outside of combat in recent
memory
the ship was left with extensive
structural electrical and mechanical
damage
and was later scrapped the sailor was a
member of the crew at the time
there are increasing concerns tonight
about china and how it may move to
strengthen its role in the middle east
as the u.s departs afghanistan a chinese
official has met with taliban
representatives
and beijing is calling the u.s effort in
that country
a failure national security
correspondent jennifer griffin has
details tonight from the pentagon
a delegation of top taliban leaders was
given a warm welcome in china this week
by top chinese officials
who experts say are seeking to position
themselves in the event of a total
collapse of afghanistan on its western
border
and fill the vacuum being left by the
united states
china has invested billions of dollars
to secure copper mining rights in
afghanistan
this is the most high profile welcome of
the taliban on the world stage by any
world leader
the two days of meetings stand in stark
contrast to the recent tense visit with
chinese officials by top american
envoy wendy sherman the taliban visit
provided an
opportunity for china to take a swipe at
the u.s
and nato the hasty withdrawal of u.s and
nato troops from afghanistan actually
marks the failure of u.s policy toward
afghanistan
and afghan people have an important
opportunity to stabilize
and develop their own country a new
congressionally mandated quarterly
report from the special inspector
general for afghanistan reconstruction
paints a bleak picture as the taliban
sweep the countryside
set up roadblocks and take over six key
border crossings
which provide them with millions of
dollars in customs revenue
to fuel the insurgency the report shows
the taliban
initiated over ten thousand attacks from
march until may
with more than two thousand civilian
casualties a record
secretary of state anthony blinken
acknowledged the taliban
have taken over more district centers in
the wake of the u.s
pullout the taliban says that it seeks
international recognition
it wants international support for
afghanistan
taking over the country by force and
abusing the rights of his people is not
the path to achieve those objectives a
message that could
be lost now that china has already given
the taliban leaders estates welcome
despite its fighters closing girls
schools and carrying out atrocities
brett story to follow jennifer griffin
at the pentagon jennifer thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else